what we did see by
mistake was like three seconds of the
nightmare scene
yeah on twitter that was going around it
was it was longer than that i think the
clip is like a minute we saw a few
seconds with you into that three seconds
we did have a moment of like whoa that's
cool
turn it off it was a very conflicting
moment because you're like i wanna keep
looking at this i wanna turn the sound
on but also i have to swipe away
what's going on reject nation more
snyder cut goodies today
so three things first thing we're gonna
react
to the cyborg trailer we're probably
gonna watch it again second thing we'll
give our thoughts on it
three thing we are going to talk a
little bit about
the snyder cut leak that happened on hbo
max yesterday bonus fourth thing the
saga
of them turning off the water and greg's
apartment
continues when i move out of here i am
unveiling the address of this place
so no one has to suffer the same fate
when you're using the bathroom and then
oh the water's turned off for the next
eight hours now this is an awesome place
to live people
can't wait for you to experience the joy
in the valley of california let's do
this
[Music]
[Music]
victor victor let's watch it again
all kinds of easter eggs i will not
understand there
whatever happened to you diana
silas these
i'm not broken
yo yo might be my favorite one yet
someone out there named w hamada
is wrestling in his chair
why is he trending why is he
i love this one zack snyder's been
saying for the longest time that cyborg
is
the heart of this story i can absolutely
see that you know victor stone
traditionally speaking victor stone
football athlete
destined for the big leagues the
accident can vary for
what led him down the path of having to
transform into cyborg does usually
involve his father having to do some of
his own science experimental stuff
to be able to keep his son alive the
dynamics with his father generally tend
to be
that his father genius level scientist
but you know
emotionally unavailable they have an
emotionally strained relationship their
mother also did die
sometimes the mother dies uh in the
process of the accident that occurs with
developing cyborg there's variations of
the tail of how it all occurred
sometimes she died beforehand all i'm
trying to get at is
victor stone has a very tragic
background it's a very tragic story this
handsome athlete who is just robbed of
his future
turned into essentially like a body
horror tale actually the show doom
patrol captures it very well
they really hone in on some strong body
horror elements especially in that first
season
they have him say that line of i'm not
broken already there you get the arc
you see where it's going and i'm not
alone i can imagine this is a guy who
feels
all those things alone and broken yeah
and then now
through this journey can find a way to
not feel alone and to see that there's a
purpose for his existence
and that this isn't just some
unfortunate fate he has to live you know
it's not a curse for all time
yeah exactly and then i think that's
like a
i don't know what that is someone will
tell us that's what we all the comments
all right all the comments will not be
the feedback on anything else we said
it'll just be me asking you forgot this
what's going on and then
like i i've i've heard that there's
supposed to be some type of visual
sequence where
victor does see all that he's capable of
or he does see his family
i think that's also from the same moment
where he's like guiding
the missiles and that one of the
trailers so this is like
a a vision or going into his own
consciousness of seeing all that he's
capable of maybe
but all the comments will tell us what
it is
i didn't shower today and uh so yeah
you're doing what
do you have no i just really enjoyed
this trailer having seen
obviously justice league but also um i
started watching doom patrol back over
christmas and i at least got part way
through the first season
uh and planned to continue it but i i
was really endeared to cyborg through
that
show especially um and then seeing this
here and looking at the other trailers
we've had
you know there's a lot of bombast
there's a lot of you know big
sort of fan service-y stuff that's been
going on and i feel like because this
movie
served back when it was first coming out
to sort of really introduce
cyborg to the dc eu in a major way this
spot sort of felt like it was the most
tonally grounded and consistent like it
really felt like i was watching a little
clip of cyborg's story less so than
a big ad for justice league that's
focused on one hero right right
so yeah i really was endeared to this
and it felt like the way that this is
expressing itself certainly made me feel
like oh yeah
probably the biggest heart of the movie
is gonna be in relating to
and looking through the eyes of victor
stone you know yeah and i i thought i
i felt like the tone of this one really
hit yeah and it wasn't like
yeah it was a new flavor also for me in
terms of the like contemplative quality
it had like there's a lot of grim
and harsh imagery for this movie it's a
very huge scenario but this one had
yeah like a more human quality even
though it is you know one of the most
enhanced and non-human-ish characters to
look at you know
yeah yeah man this is gonna be cool and
also you know
with all the unfortunate things that ray
fisher has been going through lately
i have the utmost faith he's gonna give
a very
very awesome super impressive
performance i think he's gonna kill it i
feel like after we see his performance
here
we're going to be demanding that he
continue on as
cyborg in the midst of all this chaos
he's been going through
zack snyder has still been out there
saying like i think i'm most excited for
people to see a cyborg i believe ray
fisher is going to do an
awesome job and i cannot wait to see
what he does here because i already
you know as much as that justice league
thing especially his relationship with
it one of my main takeaways
was him and esther miller we're like the
best parts of you guys
yeah even though even though you know
ray fisher's like
very outspoken about his experiences
with that movie
and so i'm like you're weirdly one of
the best parts of me today
so like tops to you for being
professional what'd you guys think of
the trailer
let's talk about the snyder cut leaks
i'll tell you guys man
so what happened was some people were
watching tom and jerry
some people clicked tom and jerry some
people were in the middle of tom and
jerry and then zack snyder's justice
league
started playing and let me tell you it
is a great movie
wow i knew this would be good but i
didn't think it'd be that good
or that funny or that funny yeah it was
really surprising
no obviously didn't catch it what we did
see by
mistake was like three seconds of the
nightmare scene
yeah on twitter that was going around it
was it was longer than that i think the
clip is like a minute we saw a few
seconds with you into that three seconds
we did have a moment of like whoa that's
cool
don't turn it off it was a very
conflicting moment because you're like i
want to keep looking at this i want to
turn the sound on but also i have to
swipe away yeah it was just like an
automatic playing thing and then it was
like three seconds like
oh my god i can't talk about that on the
internet
but you know there's there's theories
going around a very common belief that
warner brothers intentionally did this i
don't think it's any secret
that wardrobe
i don't think that's any secret uh at
all
but why tom and jerry i completely agree
with everyone on that warner brothers
been a total like they've been given
d-bags about the whole thing when it
comes to zack snyder's justice league
already thought you concluded over the
years and you
ended with zack snyder's uh interview
and vanity fair recently you're like oh
yeah okay
i honestly think it was just a mistake i
don't know what warner brothers
stands to to benefit from what do they
stand to benefit from doing
that you know test screening
somebody like the word get like they
think it's yeah
is that is the theory that i mean maybe
you guys can clarify for me it's a
theory that warner brothers thinks the
movie is so bad
that if they leak it that people go on
social media
and say it's so bad not to watch it like
i don't i don't know what the
big conspiracy is behind it like it
doesn't really
like to me it just sounds like an air
this has happened with streaming
platform maybe not for a movie on this
level of you know monumental
anticipation
but you know even recently with one
division there were people who were like
oh damn i got this early like it started
happening earlier than other people
weren't able to play it at all yeah
weird things happen
especially in the world of streaming
video where nothing is a hard copy
anymore and all sorts of things can go
wrong i will
say though that conspiracy theories
aside and
while some of them do sound rather valid
i do think it's pretty upsetting
that it does leak because this is a
movie
that since bbs people have been wanting
this especially since 2017 people have
really been wanting this and people have
fought for this
for a very long time and so it deserves
its proper release
so for it to get leaked regardless of
whether or not even if it's just a
mistake
it's still very upsetting oh yeah it's
still very annoying
i hope it's a mistake i hope it's just a
mistake too
this movie deserves its proper due it
deserves its proper release
for that to happen to this one yeah i
know
what are the odds after everything and
that's the thing is like
i guess my main question about the
conspiracy idea would be
why would warner brothers want to do
that given the fact that they're
probably banking on this to make them
some money on the subscription service
and to help keep people
whatever they don't like it yeah or have
problems unless that's just how big
their money is that they can do like
yeah just torpedo a movie out of spite
but i
i feel like that would be so detrimental
to their bottom line i mean more money
was sunk in to make this happen
and you know a lot of that came
apparently from zack snyder but they
forked over some too
so yeah why would you want to shoot
yourself in the foot and lose more money
doing it
yeah you know it's like it comes out in
10 days
i'm sure they're just making sure their
four-hour playback is gonna be fine
you know you're a con you're constantly
hearing about
on disney plus at midnight people like
can't load it can't load it
yeah and i'm just and i feel like
they're trying to avoid that with this
movie
they want people to be able to load the
server for their four-hour film
you know the most big files one of the
most anticipated movies of the year the
thing that got hbo max the most
attention before they were like let's
put everything on here yeah it was
schneider cut i feel like it was just a
mistake
either way it's a mistake that shouldn't
have occurred and if you are some
[ __ ] who's putting out leaks on the
internet to that extent
yesterday we put out our dark side
trailer reaction zack snyder was on vero
and he said that it's an ad and and rave
porter came out and
was like no it's all good it's legit i
checked it i checked it's fine and
i think there's supposed to be like a an
hd youtube version going up tomorrow but
as far as it stands it's an ad it's not
a leak but if you are putting out leaks
um i mean nothing's really gonna stop
you but i can tell you that you're an
[ __ ] you're not doing this
yeah guys this is just a fascinating
time in american history
i think tom and jerry did it that sounds
like something like tom and jerry's
shenanigans
exactly do you think wb is behind it
your thoughts down below was it mephisto
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
last but not least
pandemic jones but i did it slower this
time i'm mixing it up man
just want to shout you out say what's up
now i'm thinking your superhero origin
as
pandemic jones maybe there was an
explosion a brother box went off
your father brilliant scientist disease
jones i'm trying to make pandemic jones
a superhero origin
similar to cyborg you know what man you
got a great taste in pop music
you're someone who's always recommending
me stuff where i'm like damn i was
looking to get more
and go back to the cyborg okay so anyway
he fixes your body by taking various
viruses
and making a humanoid form out of it and
leaving the parts of you that were still
intact and from there
you can harness the power of and
communicate with any and all bacteria
which when you think about it is
actually a great ability
so you could have power over immunity
and all sorts of things man it's a good
share
with the world you're pandemic jones
it's better than osmosis jones
and now we end the video